il ya un truc qu'on ne fait pas ok ça je
vous promets que c'est vrai c'est un
truc vous le savez c'est une horloge
interne qu'on a sinon imaginer le nombre
de portes ou même de coups de poing dans
la figure qu'on pourrait se prendre
quand vous sentez les choses évidemment
vous sentez n'est jamais dragué un
hétéro de ma vie non c'est vrai que mais
jamais et alors je ne vais que quand la
porte est entrouverte je ne tape pas
devant une porte fermée montréal et fais
gaffe parce qu'il apporte eu à prendre
les violets
mais voilà il ya porte entrouverte bord
on n'a pas tout faire mais lui ça les
mecs
[Rires]
c'est une porte la porte battant de la
db4
les frais lui que j'ai plaisir à
brouiller le verrou cas pas encore la
porte entrouverte même du coup sur la
poignée c'est raymond
[Applaudissements]
tu peux dire que j'ai eu la chance à
dernière fois je veux le voir partir en
cas de corée - ils sont fort libyen
curieusement ouais il y avait des photos
de patrick swayze dans dirty ténor
[Applaudissements]
un break pas point boîte non là c'est
pas point break à une blague c'est le
film n'est guère le nom abbas et le film
référence des gays c'est parti
franchement pourquoi d'une planche sur
une planche de surf dont me excuse moi
tu soutiens le bas alors pourquoi tu
regardes et ben c'est ce que j'aime bien
ce film parce qu'avant il a envie de
prendre une grosse
lame et niveau gosses égoïstes vous avez
pas de gosses n'amène niveau côté gauche
l'acr mais alors paille d'éminents avec
la poterie ouais ouais à la crise et si
la fatigue et de la poterie quoi mais
non pas du tout non cyrille nivault
quotas hétérosexuels en est mal dans
l'émission ça peut taper là
c'est vrai qu'en plus je pense que
gilles va rejoindre la bande à gillot
assis et bacchantes et occupant dans une
douce dix ans
avant moi tu dis stop tu tape du poing
sur la table ça suffit maintenant way 50
ans d'échecs qui disent être de l'autre
côté c'est vrai avant votre séquence est
sur la mauvaise route à maman tu as well
ce qui te dis attention g avoir des vues
requis toi tu as toi tu sois pas tarder
à prendre l'itinéraire bis avec
guillaume éventuellement
sa démission et oui mais moi j'aime les
gens qu'ils dévoilent ondines à changé
d'incroyables américains à la fin de
l'année partout le général
[Applaudissements]
il
donnez la fin d'année c'est bientôt une
fête juive importante cp ça ouais on
doit tout nettoyer du sol au plafond
service gilles non mais c'est vrai que
gilles je sens que gilles gîte il est
sur le fil à il est sur le fil il se dit
est-ce qu'un moment pas tout
voilà n'a pas partie il dit mon nom mais
si elle partait toujours en place par
abdallah
guillaume à une esthétique masculin
féminin qui ne me laisse pas insensible
à ouais bah ça tombe bien parce qu'il en
est
[Rires]
vraiment
[Applaudissements]
désolé je préfère vraiment
des bad boys qui sert la manif c'est
bien que les paroles sont
aujourd'hui ça y va